este problema nos dice si x gato es
igual a x + 3g y x estrellitas es igual
a 4 x cuadrada menos ye cuadrada
encuentra el valor de menos 2 estrella
con 3 gato menos 1 va entonces nos
definen un par de operaciones y nos
piden encontrar la composición evaluado
en ciertos números vamos a hacerlo como
aquí tenemos un paréntesis tenemos que
empezar con esta operación con 3 gato
menos 1 entonces déjame hacer las de
este lado 3 gastón menos 1 muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos la definición de
gato dice cada equis vale 3 cada vez
vale menos 1 y hay que hacerle estas
operaciones
entonces x estrés nos quedaría tres más
tres por tres porque que es menos uno
y esto es igual a 33 que es igual a 0
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos 10 sale y
vale nos queda menos 2 estrella
0 va déjame marcarlo con color azul y
con color morado
y entonces ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es menos dos menos dos estrella
con 0 estrellas con 0
salehí vale entonces ahora vamos a la
definición de estrella para ver qué nos
queda aquí en la definición de estrella
dice voy a poner este 4 voy a poner este
elevar al cuadrado voy a restar aquí
ahorita pongo yo y tengo que elevar al
cuadrado entonces deje los espacios
estratégicos para poner x y xv ale menos
2 entonces aquí tengo que poner menos 2
y aquí tengo que poner ye para elevarlo
al cuadrado y llevarle 0 entonces sería
así vale entonces es 4 x menos 2 al
cuadrado menos 0 al cuadrado muy bien
vamos a ver que nos queda menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 nos quedaría 4 x 4 4 x 4 y
a eso tenemos que restarle 0 al cuadrado
o sea tenemos que restarle 0 -0 y esto
de aquí nos da 4 x 4 16 16 y ya no hay
que restar nada porque restar 0 no es
hacer nada entonces la expresión que nos
piden aquí es igual a 16